good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
wherever you're watching us around the
world this morning a sobering thought
though for a monday morning are we
heading for another world war another
week of key diplomatic efforts from
world leaders to avoid it we'll talk to
the armed forces minister james heaphy
as well as labour's shadow minister for
policing sarah jones and as the pm heads
to scotland to show it some love we'll
speak to the smp's westminster leader
ian blackford who's dubbed it a farewell
tour plus does the home secretary have a
case to answer over the state of the met
police we'll ask london's former deputy
mayor baroness jones
valentine's day
step back from the brink
uk warning to russia as leaders plan
another week of talks to try to head off
another world war
and i'm in kiev where the german
chancellor olaf schultz will meet the
ukrainian leader later this morning
and saying it with a kalashnikov the
ukrainian citizens including this 79
year old ready to defend themselves
terribly let down by the russians
reaction as a 15 year old skater accused
of taking banned drugs in december is
cleared to continue competing in the
winter olympics
a charm offensive on valentine's day as
the pm heads to scotland and north west
england on a leveling up tour
on the run police warning to women and
children after a convicted sex offender
escapes from prison in lincolnshire
[Music]
[Applause]
join in when you know the words super
bowl stardust eminem makes a political
statement during his performance as
hip-hop royalty set the stage alight for
the half-time show
happy valentine's day from dublin where
couples have been hoping that love is in
the air at this church where the remains
of saint valentine himself are kept
happy valentine's day stephen he'll be
joining us shortly also
breaking down mental health barriers for
young farmers going to be chatting with
the strictly winner turned sheep farmer
and that's kelvin fletch you remember
him from strictly
and could it be last orders for
britain's oldest pub we'll speak to the
landlord of the old fighting cox who's
looking for investment to prevent his 1
000 year old pub from closing
[Music]
hello everybody a very good morning to
you the question on many people's lips
this morning are we heading for another
world war as tensions in ukraine show no
sign of easing
now a warning to russia from the uk to
step back from the brink
the main developments this morning so
far the german chancellor will travel to
kiev this morning for a news conference
with the ukrainian president
mr zielenski spoke with us president joe
biden on sunday they agreed to keep
pushing both deterrence and diplomacy
and invited the president to come to
kiev
later this week the u.s defense
secretary ben wallace will head to
brussels for a meeting of nato defense
ministers
and boris johnson will head to europe
this week he'll join last-ditch
diplomatic efforts to ease tensions
between russia and ukraine what he calls
excuse me a critical juncture in the
crisis
well alex is in kiev he's been
monitoring events for us for a few days
now hello to um alex lots of speculation
in the papers this morning as to whether
or not we are closer to the brink today
well you'll remember of course that
there were those briefings which haven't
been
confirmed publicly that these are from
the united states
government or officials
in the intelligence community that there
could be an attack as soon as wednesday
it's clear
that this crisis i suppose the the
biggest really since the collapse of the
soviet union is now
moving towards
an extremely critical phase the
diplomacy of course is continuing for
the moment the german chancellor olaf
schultz is in town uh later he will meet
the ukrainian leader president zielenski
they will talk about the crisis it's not
clear
from the briefings that the uh the
german uh government has been putting
out whether they will put any kind of
concrete proposals of how to resolve
this crisis
what we do know is that they will talk
about help that they can give in a
practical way
to try and shore up the ukrainian
economy which of course with all this
speculation of war is taking a bit of a
battering but this is you know this is a
really difficult phase that we're moving
into lots of people really worried about
the possibility of a russian invasion
okay alex and i thanks so much indeed
should we talk about it thank you um
should we talk about it in more detail
with the armed forces minister james
heapi joining us now i've been very busy
over the last few days mr heaphy thanks
for taking the time to join us again
this morning reports in germany over the
weekend that russia could begin an
invasion as early as wednesday how
seriously are we taking that in the uk
very um i mean we've seen now
uh that there's 130 000 combat troops
around ukraine's land borders there's
thousands more on amphibious shipping in
the black sea and as of c
uh russia has concentrated artillery
missile systems and combat air in the
area and perhaps uh more ominously
although it grabs less headlines all of
the combat enablers the logistics the
fuel the medical supplies the bridging
assets are all also now in place so the
reason that the travel advice changed uh
on friday
and the urgency of the messaging since
is that the attack could effectively now
happen with no notice
that's why we've told uk citizens to
leave and as you'd imagine that's why
the diplomatic effort is being redoubled
and people in this building are working
very hard to make sure that our response
is properly calibrated
yeah and your boss as we know is
cancelled is holiday
that's what our view is in the west but
have a listen to if you would please
what the ukrainian ambassador to the uk
told me on this program last week here
we go
i believe personally that we are not
there yet and it can be avoided quite
easily and he is still raising the the
sort of hunt in the diplomatic
negotiations
doesn't his view minister is that war
doesn't seem um to be
imminent
why do we think differently
well i've heard uh jalenski say this and
my ukrainian interlocutors in their mod
when i visited a few weeks ago
were saying the same and i i hope
they're right i hope that this is just
putin amassing forces for the purposes
of diplomatic leverage
and certainly nobody in the west wants
to unnecessarily cause alarm but by the
same token we have a responsibility both
to ukraine as an ally but also to our
citizens in ukraine to be clear
on what we know
but my my nervousness k is if this was
indeed just a
play by vladimir putin to get a seat at
the negotiating table he had that when
he had 50 000 troops uh on the border of
ukraine uh but he's kept on building
them up um my fear is that it is now
very imminent indeed that's not to say
that it is definitely going to happen uh
i hope that diplomacy can win through uh
as challenging as the minsk
agreement is for the ukrainians it is uh
the framework around which a discussion
could proceed and there are other uh
mechanisms from the cold war and since
that we could revive as
confidence-building measures between
russia and the west so there are ways of
getting out of this diplomatically but
we should be absolutely clear you're
seeing it on open source it doesn't
require um secret intelligence to show
you that there is a very very worrying
very credible force now amassed around
ukraine and it's on that basis of course
that we're offering the travel advice
that we are and that causes the urgency
with which we're all working
you've written the times um this morning
minister i'm sure people will find it an
interesting read talking about cool
heads time for cool heads and a clear
message to russia um we know that your
boss um spoke ben wallace spoke the
defense secretary um the on saturday i
think comparing putin to hitler
basically did he misspeak
no i i don't think he was making any
such direct comparisons either between
uh
individuals involved in this on the
russian side and certainly not with uh
allies uh of of ours um ben was
expressing i think uh his frustration at
the apparent futility of the
diplomatic process ben has been working
on this
for months now uh he has been
to the fore in the uk government in
advocating for support to ukraine uh he
drove hard to get the lethal aid uh to
ukraine to assist in their defensive
effort
he was in moscow on friday for a very
exacting meeting with minister shoigu in
which i thought he did very well but i
know both privately and as you've seen
publicly he's deeply concerned that all
of this
could be futile and i can understand why
he's so frustrated
the ukrainian ambassador let me quote
him again because after all of course
it's the people of ukraine that have
most to lose or gain depending on which
way you look in it um he was saying it's
not the best time for us to offend our
partners in the world reminding them of
this act which actually not brought
peace but the opposite it brought war so
you know
words
quite literally could cost lives he did
misspeak didn't he
well words words matter and
i think ben
is well known to colleagues around
europe he has been traveling around all
over the place i'm certain that they
will know exactly what he meant and they
certainly know that he
doesn't mean them any uh insults or
injury whatsoever in fact quite the
reverse ben has been bringing nations
together over the last three months
as the response has been coordinated
uh ben has done a fantastic job at doing
that and indeed the ambassador himself
went back out on broadcast media
yesterday evening to clarify that
actually um the ukrainians know that ben
wallace is
one of their very best friends in the
world
and very few people have done more than
him to support them over the last few
months
the ukrainian government very keen to
join nato we've known that for some time
but also hearing that they would
potentially put that onto the back
burner if it was to avoid war do you
think that's a sensible decision
well look we've been very clear and as i
said in my article in the times that any
diplomatic solution to this shouldn't be
something that compromises the uh
ukrainian government's sovereignty and
their ability to choose which alliances
they want to be a member of now if
ukraine decides that it is going to
offer that it won't become a nato member
we support that that's for the
ukrainians to decide and there are
countries like serbia that are not
members
of nato but with whom we seek to have a
good relationship similarly if ukraine
wanted to reserve its position and say
that in the future it may want to join
nato we would support that too because
that's what sovereignty is and that's
what we support
how many british nationals have left
ukraine and how many um have you not
been able to get in touch with
well it's impossible to know how many
have left so far because this is a very
different type of country to afghanistan
there is free movement across the border
of ukraine into
the european union and people can just
get in their cars and drive across
into poland the foreign office have had
a website uh running for some time which
has allowed british nationals in ukraine
to register their details and thus allow
the foreign office to communicate
directly with them but let's be clear
kay um we are beyond the time where i'm
advising people to register on a website
i'm being very very clear to people that
they should leave ukraine now
whilst there are the commercial means to
do so and whilst the motorways are
available for them to drive out over the
border this isn't uh a warning about
something that could happen in three
months time this isn't a warning that
will be followed by further warnings
because greater imminence has been uh
has been reached this is a warning
because
minutes after putin gives the order
missiles and bombs could be landing on
ukrainian cities that means british
citizens should leave now whilst they
have the opportunity to do so
what about those brits that have
recently had
babies children and they're saying they
can't get the paperwork together in
order to get out of the country what are
we going to do about that
so i saw that case being reported in the
media over the weekend and i have every
confidence that my colleagues in the
foreign office will have seen it
whilst the british embassy in kiev
has been reduced in its staffing as you
would expect given the threat
there is still consular support uh
available through the foreign office
here in london and uh in poland as well
so i'm sure that colleagues in the
foreign office will have seen that case
being reported and that people in those
circumstances will be helped
okay um you talk about bombs and bullets
seconds after putin gives the order to
that end klm um has already uh the flag
carrier for the dutch airline has
already said uh we're not doing any
flights to ukraine for now um air lingus
or lufthansa forgive me are already
looking at that as well what's the
government's advice to our flag carrier
british airways
well the government has given advice uh
on whether or not you should travel to
uh ukraine um but forgive me and i i
might be wrong but when we were looking
at options for my trip the other week
i'm not absolutely sure that ba flies to
ukraine
oh okay
um
i might be wrong but if you know
otherwise i'll answer the question but
i'm i'm not i'm not absolutely sure it
does
okay if they do should they still be
doing it
well i think uk airlines will be making
a judgment that is based on insurance i
think is what i've read from uh other
airlines uh over the weekend um clearly
there is a very real danger of the
airspace over ukraine um becoming
hostile ukraine even if they don't land
in kiev i would have guessed
well i think if you if you recall from
previous times where there have been uh
conflicts uh airlines have always sought
to avoid that airspace and that's not
because
they fear necessarily that they will be
targeted but um
it probably sounds quite obvious but you
know when an artillery shell is fired it
goes a long way up before it comes down
so too do missiles
where's backwards and forwards and then
of course there's all the combat
aircraft going around and combat
aircraft do not identify themselves on
radars in the same way as civilian
aircraft do so i think exactly
the question
i think it's a standard operating
procedure for airlines to adjust their
routes to avoid conflict zones certainly
i recall um flying to the far east when
the iraq and afghanistan conflicts were
at their height and
routes were clearly selected to avoid
those those airspaces given what you
know is now the time for our flag
carrier to stay away from ukrainian
airspace
well that's an operational judgment for
them as it stands today there is nothing
in the airspace above
as it stands today there's nothing in
the airspace above ukraine um it's not
my place to live on your show offer
advice on whether or not an airline
should fly through a certain country's
airspace but i'm certain that the
department for transport the airlines
themselves and indeed the civil aviation
authorities of uh the countries uh that
neighbor ukraine will all be making a
judgment but for the time being
there is nothing in ukrainian airspace
that would stop you from flying over it
i think it's very tense time for
european security we can all agree uh
with that it's now the right time for
the metropolitan police commissioner to
a commissioner to have stepped down in a
fit of peak
i'm not sure i quite see the connection
between policing in london and a moment
of acute geopolitical crisis
she's also
involved in terror threats in the uk as
well isn't she she's in charge of well i
think
i think the metropolitan police force
continues to have full functionality
even in the interregnum um but clearly a
new commissioner will be appointed uh as
that process uh reaches its conclusion
okay well maybe we'll try this one see
if you've got a stronger view on this
given that the uh we have seen the
pictures of the prime minister final
question um at parties we've seen him
with tinsel uh sat next to somebody with
tinsel we've seen him eating crisps and
there we go we've seen him um with the
bottle of open bottle of very nice
champagne on the desk as well
um
should he just accept the fine pay it
move on
well i he needs i think to be found
guilty by an investigation by the police
first doesn't he
if it looks like a duck etcetera
well i i i don't know that i accept that
kate and on the one hand you know we
we've had a investigation by a senior
civil servant she
found cause to refer a number of lines
of investigation to the police which
they've now done
uh i think that
you like many members of the public and
parliamentarians are keen to see what
the police conclude i certainly don't
think the prime minister should
volunteer his culpability his argument
is that he is not culpable
we should wait and see what the police
come back with
okay just a final thought what's your
interpretation of that photograph then
if it's not him drinking
champa or being in the same place with
somebody with tinsel around their neck
taking part in a quiz and champagne
there and crisps on the desk
i don't know that is a snapshot in time
i don't know whether the prime minister
has walked into that room whilst the
other two people in the photograph are
engaged
we saw him sat down at the computer as
well didn't we that very same laptop
well i mean you're asking me to offer an
analysis of a photograph that i i don't
know the context of that photograph and
to be honest okay and i don't mean to
sound right um if there are photographs
that i'm going to spend time worrying
about today it's the photographs of
russian troop formations on the
ukrainian border that's what's fixing me
that's what's taking up my time i make
no apology for that this is a moment of
acute geopolitical crisis and all of us
in government have got a job to do
in which in which case i must let you
get on with it thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
daily telegraph leads with the rising
tension in ukraine highlighting boris
johnson's calls for russia to step back
from the brink the express emphasizes
the same message from the epm to
de-escalate the situation the final
desperate push from the west to avert an
invasion of ukraine is also on the front
page of the times the mirror reports an
increase in russian military units on
the ukrainian border
schultz plans fresh ukraine talks as
west steps up evacuations is on the
front of the ft as it looks at germany's
response and the metro also leads with
this story its headline west can't
laddy scare putin
trying too hard there the guardian has a
different lead story it looks at calls
for radical action after a race report
into britain's public health service
finds gross failings in the nhs and
finally the sun's back page leads with
kurt zuma being rushed back to london
after feeling sick and missing the west
ham game yesterday
the headline cat flap still to come on
the program for you this morning just
after eighth shadow minister for
policing sarah jones joining us as label
launches their plan to reform policing i
bet she's got a view on crested dick
even if the minister didn't
and the prime minister preparing to
visit scotland today as part of his
leveling up tour we'll speak to the snp
westminster leader ian blackford who's
described it as an advert for scottish
independence
i will speak to the former deputy mayor
of london again about crested dick's
potential replacement following her
resignation as met police commissioner
now this is a confusing story the 15
year old russian ice skater who stood
accused of doping will be allowed to
continue competing at the winter
olympics it happened back in december
tom standing by in beijing for us on
what grounds tom
morning yeah this is complicated but
what the court of arbitration for sport
was looking at their meeting last night
was whether she should be allowed to
compete they're not looking at the gold
medal that she won a part of the team
event uh last monday it's just where the
suspension could be lifted and they've
argued that it could be basically on the
grounds that there's very limited facts
in this case and that this wasn't a
positive test during the olympic games
and it's still subject to a disciplinary
procedure uh on its own merits i think
what they're saying is that this is
being investigated the uh doping result
from december but if it turned out that
actually there'd been a mistake or a
confusion and miss falliever had been
deprived of the opportunity to compete
in beijing that would be uh unfair and
caused what they call irreparable harm
now that has been met with um scorn the
u.s olympic committee said it's very
disappointed in these results and there
is also an investigation into her
entourage some people suspecting that a
15 year old might not have done this all
by herself here's what the head of the
u.s anti-doping agency said he's called
travis tiger
she has been terribly let down by the
russians and the global anti-doping
system that unfairly cast her into this
chaos and she has been at the center of
this huge amount of media scrutiny when
she takes to the eyes tomorrow in the uh
in the singles uh when she'll be
representing just by herself she's a hot
favorite but all the wise worlds will be
on her
okay thank you thanks a lot
looking at some of the day's other
headlines for you now and the rugby
football union has expressed sympathy to
the family of a young man who died
playing the sport at the weekend jack
jeffrey was fatally injured as he scored
a try for evesham he was 27.
thoughts with his family goodness
the wrongful convictions of hundreds of
people who ran post offices will be
examined by a public inquiry starting
today between 2000 and 2014 more than
700 people were wrongly accused of theft
fraud and false accounting due to a flaw
in a computer system some were jailed
while others lost everything trying to
fight for justice
an inquest is opening into the death of
the footballer emaliano sala who died in
a plane crash off the coast of alderney
in the channel islands in 2019. the
flight in which he died was organized by
david henderson he was jailed for 18
months in 2021 after being found guilty
of endangering the safety of an aircraft
a tense standoff between protesters and
police is finally over at a vital bridge
linking the us and canada truckers
opposed to coronavirus restrictions have
been removed from the ambassador bridge
by police meanwhile the number of people
protesting in canada's capital grew over
the weekend with thousands traveling to
ottawa
security footage shows how a flock of
birds dropped at mid-flight in the
northern mexican city of chihuahua last
week local police reported that close to
100 yellow-headed blackbirds simply died
and fell out of the sky toxic fumes are
a suspected cause though the authorities
still aren't certain what caused the
deaths
and just to clarify the minister was
absolutely right when he said that there
aren't any ba flights to kiev at the
moment but he's also right that the
flights do go over ukrainian air space
government not yet warning what should
and shouldn't happen as far as that is
concerned more on that to come good
morning emery is with us emma you got to
tell us about a prisoner who escaped
from a lincolnshire jail yeah police are
very concerned about this it's a man
that they describe as extremely
dangerous paul robson he was jailed in
2000
receiving two life sentences after
breaking into the home of a 23 year old
woman in oxford while she slept
he got in via the cat flap believe it or
not he put a pillow case over her head a
knife to her throat and subjected her to
a vicious sexual assault so he was
jailed for attempted rape and indecent
assault but prior to that he'd been in
and out of jail for a number of years he
was a convicted pedophile he'd attacked
girls women a girl as young as eight and
he was currently being held at hmp north
sea camp in boston in lincolnshire and
the discovery was made yesterday morning
just before seven o'clock that he'd
escaped and people are being warned not
to go near him but to call 999. uh okay
have you got a quirky phone have haven't
i
i really have i don't know where it's
come from we'll get you some hot lemon
that'll sort that out for you thanks
very much for the update emma thank you
venetians will be hoping to swap their
coved face mask with more ornate ones as
the venice carnival got officially
underway here we go dozens of
traditional boats illuminated by
coloured lights and fires paraded to the
sound of drums along the grand canal in
venice in the first weekend of carnival
celebrations
according to the carnival organizers
more than a hundred thousand people
attended the first two days more than
half of them foreign tourists the
carnival was shortened in 2020 due to
the emerging pandemic and was cancelled
completely last year now it's back
people from around the world have been
flocking to a church in the heart of
dublin believed to be the final resting
place of saint valentine uh we've sent
stephen to tell us more about white
fry's treat church in dublin tell us
more good morning
morning kay happy valentine's day from
dublin yeah that's right we're basically
here at the shrine of saint valentine's
a shrine located here in the carmelite
church in whitefire street in the city
center of dublin people will be coming
here they light a candle and they want
to say a prayer in front of the statue
here of the man himself the patron saint
of love who was executed in rome back in
the third century and this here is why
people come here on a pilgrimage in this
case behind this glass display here is a
box containing the relics of saint
valentine essentially it's bone bone
fragments and a sample of his blood it
was gifted to an irish priest back in
1835 by pope gregory the 16th he brought
it back here uh in 1836 and it was then
forgotten about largely for many years
but when the church was being rebuilt
this shrine was built in the 1950s and
these relics these remains of saint
valentine had become a major tourist
attraction as you mentioned there irish
couples couples from right around the
world come here to say a prayer and hope
that they get some sort of divine
blessing on their relationship
from saint valentine and at singletons
as well single people come here
the prior here at the church was telling
me that a new york police woman
came here said a prayer and as soon as
she got back to the big apple she found
true love so is there something to it
well over the weekend uh there were
several engaged couples here uh having
their wedding or their engagement rings
blessed uh and we spoke to a few of them
here's heather and josh and here's what
they had to say
i think we've been pretty lucky so far
anyway eight years on and he's still
putting up with me but uh not for the
rest of our lives together anyway i hope
it does and brings us the look and
fortune in the future and i'm sure
well it's great to have it so in in in
dublin like you know usually it's you
have to go to rome or places like that
to get get something cool like this or
something so important that people come
from abroad to come and see it and so
really yeah it was it's an honor to be
asked to be involved in the occasion and
hopefully it brings us a bit of luck but
i think we already have good romance
and between the two of us yeah
well they would say that wouldn't that
they had to really um last year of
course nobody could come here because of
the covet restrictions so we're hoping
to see many people many couples uh and
many single people as well come here
looking for a bit of luck and if it
doesn't work out well there'll be
something else for them as well that
statue over there okay is actually saint
jude and he's the patriot eight of
hopeless cases ah roses are red violets
are blue steven's in church especially
for you we'll see you in the next hour
thank you stephen
wasn't even very good was it i know but
he smiled lovely boy that he is quick
look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
pretty unsettled this week strong winds
and spells of rain there'll be severe
gails in places especially on wednesday
and friday it's largely frost free now
and mild in the southeast with
widespread showers and some more general
showery rain over central britain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now have you ever been
offered a generous compensation package
from a company for loss of service no me
neither well some have energy
distributed northern power grid has
apologized to dozens of customers after
accidentally issuing them with storm
armor and compensation checks for 2.3
trillion pounds one recipient took to
twitter to share pictures of the eye
watering some and ask if the company
could really afford it the power company
is currently compensating thousands of
customers who suffered power blackouts
when once in a generation wins swept
across the uk back in november do you
remember that
our top story is this morning for you as
diplomatic efforts continue aimed at
persuading russia to pull back from the
brink of conflict in ukraine the armed
forces minister tells us an attack could
happen now without any notice
[Music]
the 15 year old russian ice skater who
stood accused of doping will be allowed
to continue at the winter olympics last
week it was revealed she failed a test
she took in december for a banned
substance
and the prime minister is heading to
scotland today as part of his leveling
up tour of the uk
where his own party has called for his
resignation
so to our top story where the uk has
warned russia to step back from the
brink amid efforts by world leaders to
calm tensions on the ukrainian border
earlier i spoke to the armed forces
minister james heapey who tell me he's
worried a russian invasion could be
imminent
the reason that the travel advice
changed
on friday
and the urgency of the messaging since
is that the attack could effectively now
happen with no notice
that's why we've told uk citizens to
leave and as you'd imagine that's why
the diplomatic effort is being redoubled
and people in this building are working
very hard to make sure that our response
is properly calibrated we are beyond the
time where i'm advising people to
register on a website i'm being very
very clear to people that they should
leave ukraine now whilst there are the
commercial means to do so and whilst the
motorways are available for them to
drive out over the border this isn't uh
a warning about something that could
happen in three months time this isn't a
warning that will be followed by further
warnings because greater imminence has
been has been reached this is a warning
because
minutes after putin gives the order
missiles and bombs could be landing on
ukrainian cities
well the armed forces minister also told
me that the british government would
support whatever ukraine decides to do
on its ambition to join nato and the
ukrainians shouldn't be forced to make
compromises
any diplomatic solution to this
shouldn't be something that compromises
the uh ukrainian government sovereignty
and their ability to choose which
alliances they want to be a member of
now if ukraine decides that it is going
to offer that it won't become a nato
member we support that that's for the
ukrainians to decide and there are
countries like serbia that are not
members
of nato but with whom we seek to have a
good relationship similarly if ukraine
wanted to reserve its position and say
that in the future it may want to join
nato we would support that too because
that's what sovereignty is and that's
what we support
yeah some confusion over that because we
have heard from the
ukrainian ambassador to the uk which is
the answer to the question that i was
putting there he this is what he had
said we might shelve our plans to pursue
nato membership especially being
threatened like that blackmailed by that
and pushed to it but um
this morning he has indeed clarified
that position by saying um to avoid war
we are ready for many concessions but
they have nothing to do with nato so
perhaps uh mr speaking perhaps um
ukrainian ambassador having a word um
the ukrainian president rather having a
word with his ambassador will clarify
the situation originally saying
potentially shelving plans to join nato
if it meant
moving back from war this morning
saying no that isn't on the table
what we do know is that following dame
crested
dick's resignation as commissioner of
the met police a former deputy mayor of
london has called for her successor to
take away pensions if necessary to
reform the force it comes after the
mayor of london sadiq khan told me last
week that he won't tolerate anyone that
falls short of his expectations
if you don't get the right answers and
she's been on notice not just for this
but for many other uh occasions as i
illustrated one or two of them then it
would you you would not hesitate in
saying it's time for you to go
yeah it's very important for londoners
to know that if anybody who works for me
isn't up to the stand as long as i
expect i expect them to go
and within the day she was gone joining
us now is the former deputy mayor of
london baroness jones of moscow uh jenny
jones hello to you uh baroness jones
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning um are you happy that
crested dick stepped down
i'm not happy about it but i think it
was the right decision and it was long
overdue
as commissioner she's got so many big
calls completely wrong the policing of
the sarah everard vigil the uh not
dealing properly with the corruption
over the daniel morgan case and so on
it's just been endless and it strikes me
that this is a chance now to actually do
some really big reforms for the met
police it's not easy it's going to be
very tough because of all sorts of
reasons from the past but at the same
time it has to be done if it's going to
reclaim some public trust
how do you go about that you've
previously said
um that sarah everard's killer wayne
cousins as we know he was a serving uh
police officer you said he was protected
by a toxic culture within the police
force i believe how do you
root out that toxic culture
it's incredibly difficult i mean back in
2010 when boris johnson was mayor of
london there were some huge budget cuts
to the met police
which i think rendered them less able to
do the job properly there are all sorts
of background staff which were cut who
did valuable work obviously and also a
lot of middle rank officers have just
had enough quite honestly and they left
people like sergeants
and then there's been a rush to um
reinvigorate the met and get all sorts
of new recruits now that means if you're
going to do that in a hurry you need to
make sure that your recruitment and your
vetting are absolutely top-notch and i
think that that has failed
and also of course when officers are
called out
in terms of um having done something
wrong they've really got to be brought
to justice whatever that means and
sometimes that will mean being sacked
and not having their pensions i'm not
saying that should happen all the time
i'm just saying that
everything has to be treated in a way
that if they were an ordinary member in
public they would be treated and so
it is a very tough job and we've got a
lot of candidates for it uh it'll be
very interesting to see who wins through
does it need to be a serving police
officer or does the net need to be cast
wider than that
i think um
that's an interesting question and i
don't particularly uh support the idea
but on the other hand if there were if
there was a candidate who had
the right credentials um there's always
been various sort of rules unwritten
rules about uh who can take on the top
job for example you had to have left the
net for another force and come back but
there's never been any sort of um
view of whether or not you should have
run a big organization i think that was
one of the problems for christopher dick
she had not
run a different force now it's not to
say that different forces apart from the
met don't have their problems we've just
seen greater manchester police being
found um well
hopelessly um racist and
corrupt so
we've got big problems not only in there
but but all over the country and so this
is a very big decision for pretty patel
and quite honestly i don't trust her to
make the right decision so it's going to
be fascinating watching her
okay looking at uh images there of uh
crested with the mayor of london
what role should the mayor of london
have in choosing the next
um chief commissioner
well back in um from 2000 to 2012 we had
a met police authority and i was part of
that for those 12 years and we did
actually help choose the next
commissioner and i think it was a good
system not having it as one person's um
say so and so i think uh saliq khan as
mayor should have a large say in who
comes next because here's the person who
is um going to have to hold them to
account in london and that's where um
you know
where the problems are and so i would
say uh it's not only pretty patel's
decision that sadiq khan has to be
involved as well
um some suggesting that in fact pretty
patel um was complicit um in the
failures of
the shadow home secretary yvette cooper
speaking at the weekend and saying that
she'd failed peter patel had failed to
tackle systemic and cultural issues
including reforms to training vetting
and misconduct strategy
absolutely i mean pretty patel shouldn't
be imposed either but clearly while we
have this prime minister
in coast he's going to cling on to
people he sees as loyal i'm afraid this
is a much bigger problem than just met
corruption met homophobia or misogyny
and racism this is actually an endemic
we've got huge problems at the moment
and i can't
wait for the next general election
um and as far as um getting a new
commissioner how quickly do we need to
do that
well clearly um christopher dick is
going to stay in post until that happens
i mean it takes a while because you have
to be sure about the person so i would
imagine it would be at least a couple of
months and
uh it will be fascinating to
see if the front runners supposedly
front row runners actually do get the
post it's quite
obvious that whoever comes next has to
be very tough and have a zero tolerance
attitude towards all the problems that
the nets had in the past that is going
to be extremely hard and so
it's got to be somebody who's got a
perhaps a track record of rooting out
these problems and at the moment i can't
quite see anybody on the list
um so it does look as though well
all being well that she crested it will
still be overseeing what happens with
the uh with partygate at downing street
you think
yes that's going to be an interesting
moment because of course she dragged her
feet it was her decision
i mean i made complaints to the
independent office for police conduct i
make complaints to
the mayor of london's office and and so
on and
and lots of other people did too
hundreds of people wrote in saying you
have to investigate this and her
dragging her feet on that i'm afraid was
complicity with a corrupt government
good to talk to you very much jones
thank you very much indeed for joining
us on the program thank you
just checking um the latest as far as
our tweets are concerned just putting
those up for you now as far as mr hippie
the armed forces minister you can check
those out right now on our twitter feed
at haberly and um putting them together
for you today are ben and sophie now new
figures show there's been an 85 increase
in the number of people waiting for a
new heart now the nhs is urging families
to have what it calls a heart to heart
about organ donation as of may 2020 a
change to the law allows for your organs
to be automatically donated when you die
but individuals can opt out
if they want to
six thousand people are waiting for an
organ transplant in the uk 6 000 people
300 of whom are waiting to receive a new
heart
however just 43 percent of the
population have registered their
decision to remain in the system or opt
out katie barnfield reports
enjoying playing with her son jaden
something that's only possible for
caroline sofronio because a heart
transplant saved her life
before my transplant i was unable to
walk out the house
it kind of gradually got to a point
where i couldn't hold a conversation
um i was so out of breath they gave me
uh
a week to live
but now she has to watch jaden going
through the same thing
they both have dannon's disease a
hereditary condition that causes heart
failure
he's been waiting for a new heart for
six months his first year of life he was
in and out of hospital it could have
been
every
week
the rest of my family
haven't survived it because there wasn't
a heart
there
quick enough every day is
a constant struggle
what if you know or you always have that
hanging over you
the number of people waiting for a heart
transplant has gone up 85 percent over
the last decade and because of the need
to find smaller organs children often
have to wait much longer
although you now have to opt out of
being an organ donor the nhs say nearly
two-thirds of people still haven't told
their family about their wishes which
can stop donations going ahead
families faced in this situation will
always be asked about their loved ones
decision and will always be asked about
organ donation there is always a demand
supply gap with organ donation and
transplantation in the country so it's
really important that we all talk to our
families and let our families know what
our decision would be they say it's only
by getting more people confirmed as
donors that more lives like caroline's
and jaden's can be saved casey barnfield
sky news
uh covered now let's have a quick look
at the latest data for you there have
been another 41
270 cases recorded in the last 24 hour
period that's down a third on last
week's number and the lowest daily
figure since the end of november of last
year a further 52 people have sadly died
that brings it to 159
570 deaths in the uk within a
24-28-day period of being confirmed as
having coveted
amnesty international has accused big
pharmaceutical companies of monopolizing
vaccine technology arguing firms are
prioritizing wealthier nations let's get
more on that now with amnesty
international's programme director for
global issues mark dammit hi mark thanks
for joining us um what has this report
found discovered
thanks for having me on your show cave
um the report looks back at last year
and the record of pharmaceutical
companies and
wealthy nations such as our own
and really found that
their response was pitiable
i mean
the uk pharma companies prioritized
supply to wealthier parts of the world
and de-prioritize supply to poorer parts
of the world and obviously to a certain
extent we've benefited from that with
you know you've just presented those
encouraging figures of
uh case rates here in the uk going down
but there are other parts of the world
poorer nations where a tiny fraction of
the population has been vaccinated in
low-income countries um the statistics
show that up to the end of last year
only four percent of people were
vaccinated
and we've heard it many times but no one
is safe until we're all safe the risk is
that there's going to be there are going
to be more variants
um you know putting ourselves at risk
not you know and that's that's you know
beyond of course the fact that
in those populations with low
vaccination rates they're very much
exposed still
to to covet while cases are going down
in places like like like the uk
talk to me about astrazeneca um widely
um hailed as a trailblazer when it comes
to vaccinations um and the equality of
sending those vaccinations around the
world do they deserve that reputation
so we've ranked the major
vaccine well all of them the the major
vaccine developers and astrazeneca does
come out if you want to you want to put
it that way they come out the best um
they're the ones who've prioritized from
the beginning distributions to
the whole world
um they came out at the beginning with a
with a very clear and strong commitment
not to make a profit during the pandemic
period and that contrast very favorably
say to pfizer which has
very much prioritized sales to north
america europe and other wealthy nations
and has made an enormous profit
um uh almost 30 billion uh pounds last
year it made from its vaccines it's one
of the most profitable medicines in
history
so yeah astrazeneca scores on on our
assessment much better than pfizer
however astrazeneca's also along with
the other companies blocked efforts to
lift
intellectual property restrictions which
would allow
manufacturers around the world including
in the global south from making these
vaccines for themselves
and you know the argument of the drug
companies is we need these patent
protections that's our business model
you've got to trust us we're the ones
who develop
um this groundbreaking technology and
science
this is how the this is the model which
works for us
and also that even if we did allow
uh lift these patent protections it
would take a long time for manufacturers
around the world to get up to speed
but our argument and those of others
including the world trade organization
is that that's not good enough this is a
a once in a generation crisis
we need to do everything we can to get
the world out of this crisis
and and you know part of that is surely
you know lifting these protections and
encouraging global production
okay it's good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for explaining that to
us thank you joining us now is dr fiona
atawebe
medical officer at the world health
organization for africa dr fiona thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning what do you make of this report
i think it's still an appalling report
thank you very much for hosting me it's
an appalling report and the rhetoric is
the same since the
we started the pandemic and of course
the iniquity has been very evident uh in
in africa
the global north and the global south
and the poorer countries and of course
we know that the longer the inequitable
access persists
the longer the pandemic will drag on and
as the report says that uh the longer we
have it the more we are giving the
chance to the virus to mutate and once
the virus continues circulating and
mutating it goes back to a global
problem it is a once-in-a-lifetime
crisis can we not join hands to solve
this crisis
which african countries are most in need
of extra support
okay so we'll we have only seven out of
54 african countries that met that
december 40
um
target that we sent would set globally
for
for vaccination to have 40 percent of
the can each country's population fully
vaccinated we only have 7 out of 54. so
if i was to list it's basically the
whole of africa that still is in great
need for support but majorly we have the
the bigger countries that have high
populations the democratic republic of
congo the ethiopians the nigerians
countries like chad we have countries
like sudan but then we also have
countries that are generally high in
humanitarian crisis countries like
african republic we have countries that
are geographically difficult to maneuver
like south sudan we also have our
our usual countries that lag behind we
have
burundi that recently started but is
still finding issues to scale up
has not had even a single citizen
vaccinated in that country so we still
have a lot of to deal with in africa
is it about supply doctor or is it about
once it's there being able to make sure
that people who need it get um
access to it
so we did finally manage to get over the
supply constraints which i would like to
thank the donors the g7 that really went
out of the way and donated vaccines to
africa
however we know that this vaccine has
become is is a bit unique because it
comes with short shelf life so it's no
longer about the supply we are dealing
with the supply chain requirements which
and of course the duration of shelf life
but also when it comes to vaccine one of
the vaccines that we had in huge amounts
was the fisa vaccine the handling of the
fisa vaccine the ultra cold chain can
only be managed in uh the cities that
capital cities are in african countries
so having to and most of the populations
don't live in the cities they live in
the rural areas so getting the vaccine
out of the rural areas
leave it there we must leave it there
i'm so sorry we are out of time thank
you so much uh for explaining the
situation to us uh coming up in just a
few moments time government minister who
says we could be hours away from bombs
raining down on ukraine we'll give you
the context in a minute
you